on est prêt
c'est aveuglé par les agences irritantes
Victoria Aymard tente de s'orienter pour
retrouver son véhicule de patrouille
l'instructeur demande à la future
policière du SPVM de repousser un
suspect qui s'est emparé de son poivre
de Cayenne c'est bon
est soumis à la même épreuve la
formation de 18 semaines est difficile
tant sur le plan mental que physique
elle et lui ont en commun de faire
partie de la toute première corde de
l'histoire de l'École nationale de
police du Québec réservée à la police de
Montréal c'est le ministère de la
Sécurité publique qui a fait cette
demande en nous dernier pour envoyer
rapidement des renforts ou svvm aux
prises avec une flambée de violence
armée s'est recrues acceptent donc de
venir à Montréal même si leurs
interventions mouvementées en plus de
chances de se retrouver sous l'oeil des
médias et des caméras citoyennes peu
importe le métier qu'on va faire de la
vie va avoir des pressions qui vont
venir on se joignant au spbm c'est 72
policiers obtiennent une promesse
d'embauche et on peut éviter une attente
d'eau moyen un an avant d'entrer à
l'École nationale de police j'ai passé
deux été comme SPVM j'ai fait partie de
la brigade urbaine qui était attitrée au
PDQ 20 en 2020 j'ai fait partie du
pédicte 38 en 2021 ça a été deux super
belle expérience
de recrues motiver il en faudra beaucoup
au cours des prochaines années d'ici
trois ans près de 1700 policiers parmi
les quelques 4400 au SPVM seront
admissibles à la retraite c'est sans
compter les nombreuses d'émissions après
38 policiers ont quitté le spbm en 2022
pour poursuivre leur carrière à la SQL
le nouveau directeur du SPVM fait du
Daguerre tenait à être là non seulement
pour les encourager à compléter leur
formation mais aussi pour leur dire
qu'il ferait tout pour appuyer ses
futurs protégés faites votre travail du
mieux possible s'il y a des erreurs je
vais être là pour vous ce qui est
défendable je vous défendre mais le
directeur de la guerre l'aura aussi
précisé qu'il ne serait pas là pour
défendre l'indéfendable vous avez vu les
vidéos de mes fils l'agression et la
personne décédée je vous défendrai
jamais plus on avançait dans
l'intervention
plus et pas du tout des techniques
enseignées puissant ça fait mal à toute
la profession policière c'est un Memphis
ça nous fait mal au Québec ça nous fait
mal à Montréal très attentif les recrues
du SPVM ont écouté attentivement la
vision du futur patron je peux pas me
permettre que un deux ou trois personnes
du SPVM fasse mal à toute le service
s'ils ont travaillé très très mal en
considérant que Montréal compte pour 72%
de la criminalité au Québec fatigue la
guerre fait valoir qu'un policier qui
décide d'y faire carrière peut avoir un
impact significatif vous allez faire
face à plein de choses c'est vrai par
contre c'est l'endroit le plus occupé
c'est fou 30 ans vous allez rien voir ça
va passer extrêmement vite puis
franchement c'est extrêmement valorisant
le salaire de base de 36900 dollars
qu'offre le SPVM à ses recrues et les
difficultés d'accès à un logement
abordable sont source de préoccupation
pour Victoria qui quittera
Trois-Rivières pour Montréal tu dis des
soucis au niveau des salaires
l'attraction est-ce que ça te fatigue
on va régler ça
la Fraternité des policiers policières
de Montréal confirment que les
conditions salariales des recrues sont
au cœur de l'actuel ronde de négociation
avec la ville c'est pas très avantageux
présentement devenir à Montréal et
on travaille là-dessus pour
effectivement non seulement qui viennent
chez nous mais qui demeure au SPVM les
organisations policières offrent
désormais des primes de tout genre pour
attirer les recrues qui sortent
fraîchement diplômés le NPQ qui formait
648 policiers annuellement prévoit
s'adapter à la demande accrue générée
par les départs à la retraite on est en
demande auprès du gouvernement du Québec
effectivement pour nous permettre
d'avoir une formation de 350 aspirants
aspirants policiers de plus donc environ
1000 policiers par année qui sont formés
quand tu as eu Victoria et Camillo se
disent très motivé de travailler sous
des ordres de fady Daguerre
c'est de gratter pour comprendre pour
éviter que la semaine prochaine on y
retourne encore moi je voulais quelque
chose de dynamique comme ça
Montréal c'est la réponse merci beaucoup
de chance
c'est le 6 avril prochain que Camille
love Victoria et leur corps seront
officiellement en poste dans la
métropole
ici Pascal robinet